if there is a front line in the fight to
save endangered species then this is it
we're deep in the rain forests of
northern Vietnam it's 1:00 a.m. and
we're at a unique conservation facility
UN van tae is a man whose life mission
is to save the most unusual of creatures
this is the Pangolin shy nocturnal
entirely harmless and oddly and chanting
the only mammal covered in scales it
curls into a ball to fend off predators
it's a creature invincible to everything
in the wild except man it really should
be a privilege to be as close to a
creature as we're an extraordinary
looking as this but it's a bittersweet
privilege because in just a few years
these animals could well be hunted to
extinction and here's why a crate of
live pangolins destined for China but
confiscated on the border poachers have
force-fed them corn flour and gravel to
increase their weight and their value
they vomited out a hundred thousand
pangolins a year our hunted and traffic
like this yeah a lot of waste people in
Vietnam and China are looking to it's
appalling using family scale for the
chilies and a medicine to anymore at the
quarantine section we meet one of those
from the crate recovering well another
though is horribly wounded a snare has
slit its neck its tongue is protruding
he'll just put to sleep shortly after
this forest was once their home as a
child ty remembers how common they were
now the forest is being chopped down and
the creatures hunt deforestation in
Vietnam we follow the poachers trail on
the roads at annoying
this is the streets where the medicine
shops are and it's where all the
Pangolin scales and now within a few
minutes we're offered what we're looking
for what's what's this
does a penguinese scale this is the
Penguins so why is she selling it if
it's illegal
no problem thank you very much it said
that Pangolin scales can cure cancer but
there's no science to back that up at
another shop we find they're not even in
the back room so $80 for a hundred grams
they're not confiscating as we've been
to three shops now and we've it's been
very easy to buy yeah you know that one
of the problem with the law enforcement
they're not working effectively that was
really interesting we had a longer chat
there was someone in the sense you get
is this
they're aware it's illegal they know the
pangolins can well be extinct in a few
years but they just don't care it's
almost as if when one species runs out
simply move on to the next the Soviet
number I'll add mint ideally we drive
across town with Thai restaurants here
openly but illegally served Pangolin we
can order it the waitress says but it
will take an hour to deliver again she
warns us that it is illegal but not to
worry they have a relationship with the
government who come here to eat it
themselves
this dead Pangolin was filmed secretly
by Thai in a restaurant kitchen the
scales are removed before the meat is
prepared to eat we move on to a district
specializing in exotic meats the legal
fair is on display the illegal pangolins
aren't here but they are on offer
complete with a picture on the waiters
phone back at the conservation reserve
Thai has used funding from Yuki Zoo in
the UK to recruit hide equine an animal
behavioral expert I can't overestimate
the the wonder that they survive at all
it's truly incredible the very real
possibility exists that they're going to
be eaten to extinction if we don't save
the Pangolin then what else do we let go
it is a difficult battle and the odds
aren't with them mark stone Sky News in
Vietnam